special counsel Robert Muller seems to
be almost done with his nearly two-year
investigation of Russian election
interference sources tell CBS News
Muller will deliver his final
confidential report to the Justice
Department before Deputy Attorney
General rod Rosen Stein leaves in a few
weeks but it could be done within days
President Trump said yesterday that
Attorney General William Barr will
decide whether the full report is
released Barr has not confirmed how much
of Muller's findings he will disclose to
Congress or the public in his
confirmation hearings he said he would
be as transparent as possible Paula Reid
is at the White House she's followed the
Russia probe from the beginning and has
learned more about Muller's final report
Paula good morning we've heard for a
long time it's coming it's coming it's
coming why is the report actually
possibly coming now there are a lot of
signs we're seeing here in Washington
first of all the molar grand jury has
not been spotted for several weeks and
this comes after former acting Attorney
General Matthew Whitaker said he expects
the probe to wrap up soon we're also
seeing for the first time in the Roger
stone case the Special Counsel teamed up
with local prosecutors local US
Attorney's here in Washington on that
case now that makes it easy if the
special counsel dissolves or wraps up
its work they can pass the case off to
the local US Attorney's to take to its
completion how likely are we to see the
report well it's all up to attorney
General William Barr that regulation
requires that the special counsel submit
a report to the Attorney General but
there is no requirement that anything be
made public and during his confirmation
hearing Barr vowed transparency he
suggested that he would release a
summary of Muller's findings but House
Democrats have made it clear they're not
interested in bars summary and they've
said anything short of the full report
being released will prompt them tissue
subpoenas for the report
Paula 34 people have been charged as a
result of this probe and I know that
you've read just about every word of
every one of these documents so you're
an expert on this I mean tell us what
you think will be in this final report
in the final report that bar receives he
is going to be able to read a lot about
people they investigated and decided not
to charge but traditionally the Justice
Department keeps that confidential
information confidential it's not
released to the public the idea is in
this country you may be investigated but
if you were not charged that information
about you shouldn't be out in the public
hanging over your head
so that's going to be a lot of what is
new in this report but because that
information is not typically released to
the public I don't think we're gonna get
a lot of new information I really do
think what a based on what I've read the
special counsel has been telling this
story through the charging documents
that's why so many of these these
charging documents are so lengthy and
they're so detailed the special counsel
has been trying to tell the story
through the documents that people have
charged we haven't seen a narrative
essentially for everyone wrapping it all
together and connecting the dots
essentially outlining the criminal
conspiracy or collusion if you will do
you expect that I do not at this point I
do not think that they are going to
charge anyone with a conspiracy between
Russia or anyone in the campaign they've
and other people who have run afoul of
other laws but at this point it is not
my expectation that anyone will be
charged with conspiracy or was people
like to call it collusion